me as the leader of the free world
can you explain this to me first he was
with trump
now you want to run against him yeah
that's confusing to me i just think
musically he should find himself cause i
heard some of this music and it sounds
amazing
whole life being thugs no choice selling
drugs
politics is very tricky and that's
something that you can't just jump into
look at donald trump
he jumped into politics look at the
results of it someone who has no
knowledge no
heart no understanding to what a
politician is is a businessman
but this ain't business there's no
confusion over how snoop feels about pal
jimmy kimmel's blackface scandal
the late night host came under fire for
spoofing the rapper over 20 years ago
i know you're good with jimmy kimmel if
you had a chance to talk to him is he
gonna be okay
i just feel like jimmy kimmel shouldn't
be crucified for something he did in the
past
based off of who he's become he's a
lovable guy
he's a family man i didn't deal with him
a hundred times
he has no racist blood in his heart i
got a character named todd that's a
white guy well my bros want me to tell
you about this new website
white guys connect that's not racist
that's me tapping into
something that i feel that's humorous
it's everything i want to taste to the
wine
yup snoop's gone from gin and juice to
wine with snoop's cali red
the product of his collaboration with 19
crimes
launching this week i got you i got you
right oh i like that your top on the
bottom is gangsta
if you put your phone next to the bottle
and move it to the left or move it to
the right
the bottle will talk to you what they
call me the dog father
king of the west coast has marca tried
this [ __ ]
no we got martha she got her we got a
couple of cases coming to her you know i
can't give her one bob
she's gonna blow that on the on her
meals